je joins maintenant à moncton monsieur
charles doucet qui a été témoin de la
fusillade d'hier tout près de chez vous
monsieur doucet
bonsoir à vous pourquoi donc racontez
moi d'abord vous êtes vraiment dans ce
quartier moncton nord et vous avez
entendu hier soir les coups de feu et
bientôt la première indication qu'on a
reçue qu'il y avait quelque chose hors
de l'anonymat qu' français dans la
région c'était sur les médias sociaux
une éducation qu'il y avait quelqu'un
avec des fusils qui se commet dans la
région puis qu'il y avait eu des coups
de feu aussi l'échangé
j'ai attendu quelques minutes pour que
ça sent qu'ils lisent un petit peu puis
j'ai sorti des puits jusqu'à 7 ans de la
maison j'ai entendu une série de coups
de feu est probablement quinzaine de
coups de feu échangés à tous et jill et
borges est rentré dans la maison j'ai
fermé sa porte pour tirer les rideaux
tout le reste j'ai attendu quelques
minutes pour avant de ressortir
puis me suis rendu c'est seulement
alentours de 75 mètres de chez nous que
la 12e solitude yade s'est déroulé j'ai
parlé des voisins qui m'ont indiqué
qu'il y avait quelqu'un qui avait été
abattu je pense qu'ils soupçonnaient que
c'était peut-être le sida qui avait été
abattu mais lors immédiatement ils
disent aussi l'agencé qui sont sortis et
dana reeve l'arrière d'une maison qui
nous ont dit de son échine tout de suite
parce que le titre est encore libre
concurrence et je me suis tourné de bord
je me suis barricadés dans la maison
puis ç'a commencé
voyons maintenant 24 heures deux fois
sangouard de de stress d'anxiété
tout le reste on a passé des moments
vraiment parfois tranquille parfois
effrayant
parce qu'il faut qu'on parle monsieur
doucet pour les téléspectateurs que vous
avez deux jeunes enfants de 6 ans et 4 1
rebonds consorts on retourne pas se
coucher c'est pas un orage qui passent
là c'est c'est ça continue on sait pas
ce qui arrive il est toujours au large
le monsieur est exactement puis là il ya
des moments aujourd'hui qu'il ya fallu
qu'on explique davantage qu est ce qui
se passait nos enfants qu'il ya un
méchant qui étaient cachés dans les bois
en arrière chez nous que les policiers
étaient là pour essayer de retrouver les
mettre en prison mais c'est quand même
ça s'explique un petit peu mal parce que
c'est pour la police ordinaire en voyant
ces envois des dix marques aspirants
camouflage avec des mitraillettes puis
tout le reste
puis il ça nous arrivait des genres
trois fois maintenant on était à 1 euro
en retrait dans le sous sol puis que
tout à coup quelque chose qualifie les
policiers sont là devant nous à des tops
qui le disent à leur bord c'est quand
même difficile et il a ça c'est la
première nuit il ya une deuxième nuit à
venir qu'est ce que la police vous dis
d'abord évidemment de rester à la maison
de nouveau ressortir le bar et les
partis tous et anciennement nous donne
aussi un peu d'informations sur la
manière qu'on devrait se contenter sur
les médias sociaux
apparemment particulièrement et avoir
dit du dans la nuit
dans un effort pour partager de
l'information il ya beaucoup du public
qui ont tant tragique d'informations au
sujet du détournement des officiers de
la gendarmerie puis après la mort le
tireur avait sur lui un téléphone
cellulaire qui chausse du jean py qui
suivait les mouvements les policiers
puis saluer lui a aidé beaucoup donc
nous demande maintenant de six d'être
plus discrets dans ce qu'on met sur les
médias sociaux et dans l'est en
terminant monsieur doucet dans votre
quartier toujours barricadées dans des
genres et agisse calmement d'après ce
que vous pouvez en général mélange il ya
plusieurs de mes voisins maintenant
qu'ils ont opté de s'enfuir qui sont
parties de la ville on a eu cette option
qui nous a été offerte cet après-midi
sauf que s'ils ont choisi de sortir de
la ville on n'a pas le droit de le
trouver
ah ouais ouais bon écoutez je vous
souhaiteraient pas un bonne nuit ce sera
un peu imbécile mais je vais vous dire
qu'on souhaite tout le monde que l'on
que l'on trouve cet homme justin bourque
le plus vt merci de nous avoir parlé
derrière au revoir
pourquoi